while 19th century London was a place
where dreams often met dead ends one
boy's curiosity would light up the world
we take electricity for granted today
but have you ever wondered who made
these discoveries possible Michael
Faraday came from the slums and
revolutionized physics born in 1791
Faraday grew up in a poor neighborhood
south of the River Thames life was
incredibly harsh largely due to the
Industrial Revolution which brought a
massive influx of people into the city
leading to severe overcrowding and
abysmal sanitary conditions Faraday
recalled being given one loaf of bread
that had to last him for a week hardly
enough to sustain him but he received
plenty of spiritual sustenance from his
family's small Christian sect Faraday
learned to read and write at Sunday
school he barely had a primary school
education what he lacked in money and
education he made up for with an
insatiable curiosity he started working
as a book binder at the age of 13.
finding books our after hour or day
after day the only perk was his ability
to read every book he could get his
hands on the more he read the more he
understood what he lacked in education
he tried his best to speak well and made
sure his friends corrected him when he
didn't one of his favorite books
emphasized the importance of critical
thinking and The crucial role of
observation in understanding the world
around him
this book deeply impacted Faraday
teaching him to rely on careful
observation during his groundbreaking
experiments growing up he heard about
the discovery in Italy by Alessandro
Volta of the voltaic cell or battery
which for the first time ever provided a
continuous flow of electricity before
that devices like tin foil line glass
jars stored electricity but released
their charge in a single burst the idea
of a continuous stream of electricity
ignited A Fire Within Faraday how could
he choose any other career other than
one in science Faraday managed to snag a
ticket to attend a lecture by Sir
Humphrey Davey at the Royal Institution
where eminent scientists presented their
research a customer at the book
strawberry worked William dance had been
impressed with Faraday's passion for
Science and offered him a free ticket
Faraday was mesmerized by the lecture
mainly recording every word in his notes
he hoped to get a job at the esteemed
scientific Academy the Royal Society
only to find out later that when he
wrote to its president sir Joseph Banks
they Banks or perhaps the secretary had
written on the letter he sent no answer
required Faraday wondered if he was
destined to bind books for the rest of
his life but then he got a break the
Bookshop customer who had given Faraday
the ticket to see Humphrey Davy
suggested Davey hire Faraday when Davey
was temporarily blinded by an explosion
in his lab and needed help this was just
a temporary position the only permanent
opening Davey had of the Royal
Institution was for a bottle washer he
had to fire the one he had for fighting
it was the lowest of low positions at
the institution but it was a foot in the
door and Faraday accepted Davey
recognized his talents and soon he
became a lab assistant helping with
experiments like extracting sugar from
beetroot working for Davey afforded him
a unique opportunity to travel across
Europe mingle with leading scientists
and open his eyes to the world quite the
journey for the son of a blacksmith who
had never ventured outside of London he
built a reputation as a proficient
chemist then the frontier of science he
analyze the gases emitted by aging eggs
tested methods of drawing various meats
and fish as food for Sailors and
isolated the organic chemical compound
Benzene then came bombshell news that
turned his attention to another domain
in science Hans Christian ersted in
Denmark had put a magnetic compass near
his battery and was surprised to see
that the compass needle moved his
Discovery revealed that an electric
current can generate a magnetic field at
the time few scientists thought there
was any connection between electricity
and magnetism the French physicist Andre
Marie ampere then described the
intricate link between electricity and
magnetism through a detailed tapestry of
mathematical formulas these math models
were completely foreign to Faraday
because of his limited education it was
akin to reading Chinese yet his lack of
Education may have been a blessing in
disguise
since Faraday couldn't lean on formulas
and equations he leaned into his
intuition and powers of observation he
had to do his own experiments to
understand a topic which pushed him to
design experiments that others hadn't
dreamed of one of his early experiments
showed how electricity and magnetism
could produce motion he stuck a magnet
at the bottom of a glass container then
filled the glass with a conductive
liquid mercury in his case water with
table salt in our case he dangled a wire
over the cup when he passed an electric
current through the wire the wire
rotated around the magnet this
rotational motion was due to the
interaction between the magnetic field
produced by the electric current in the
wire and the magnetic field of the
magnet Faraday had built the world's
first electric motor fast forward to
today and the legacy of this principle
can be seen every time a Tesla Glides
past you on the road EVS are descendants
of Faraday's foundational work of
turning electrical energy into motion
his friend and brother-in-law George
helped with the experiment and recalled
I shall never forget the enthusiasm
expressed in his face and the sparkling
in his eyes Faraday on the other hand
wrote in his journal simply very
satisfactory but make a more sensible
apparatus he published his work in a
scientific journal which catapulted him
to fame much to the apparent jealousy of
Sir Humphrey Davy who was now being
overshadowed by his former bottle
cleaner Faraday became a fellow of the
Royal Society his Friday evening
lectures at the Royal Institution became
hugely popular he also began to give
Christmas lectures for kids at a time
when education for children was rare the
tradition continues today Faraday
emerged as England's leading lecturer on
science he was offered numerous
opportunities in Consulting that would
have made him very wealthy but he chose
the pursuit of science over financial
gain
while his professional life took off his
personal life blossomed too he fell in
love with George's sister a 19 year old
Sarah they were devoted to one another
their whole lives which was an about
face for someone who was once
pessimistic about love writing what is
the pest and plague of human life and
what is the curse that often brings a
wife tis love
they had no children of their own yet
lived Rich lives Sarah supported him in
any way she could in assuring he ate
nourishing food and making sure he had
time to relax after hard work in his
laboratory 10 years had passed since his
famous electric motor experiment though
he had made other discoveries in between
something was nagging at him if an
electric current could produce a
magnetic field could the reverse be true
could a magnetic field induce an
electric current many had tried all but
failed yet Faraday persisted his
observations led him to a critical
Insight it wasn't just the presence of a
magnetic field that could induce an
electric current but the change in the
magnetic field electricity only forms
when the magnet is moved when he moved a
magnet inside a coil of wire he induced
an electric current but when the magnet
was stationary no current was observed
this groundbreaking work demonstrated a
two-way relationship while electric
currents can produce magnetic fields the
converse is also true a changing
magnetic field leads to the creation of
electric currents a principle known as
electromagnetic induction
consider Niagara Falls the falling water
turns big turbines which then spin
magnets around coils of wire this
creates shifting magnetic fields in the
coils and just as Faraday discovered
these changing magnetic fields generate
electric currents from there the
electricity is transmitted through power
lines straight to your home while
Faraday's experiments were
groundbreaking it took some serious math
skills which he lacked to realize their
true potential enter James Maxwell he
took the findings of Faraday and others
and translated their pioneering work
into a set of comprehensive mathematical
formulas now recognized as Maxwell's
equations these equations elegantly
Express how electric and magnetic fields
are intertwined ultimately leading to
the identification of electromagnetic
waves like radio waves microwaves
visible light and x-rays this
understanding later played a pivotal
role in the creation of radios TVs and
in due course cellular communication so
Faraday's Hands-On EXP Germans combined
with Maxwell's theoretical Mastery lay
the foundation for today's technological
era
Faraday was deeply interested in
understanding the fundamental nature of
forces and finding a unifying
explanation for them all his faith drove
his deep curiosity as he saw the laws of
nature as the handiwork of God and by
studying them he was studying the Divine
he speculated about the possible
relationship between electricity and
gravity to no avail some of his peers
thought his limited math skills made him
ill-equipped for advanced theorizing as
the years passed Faraday's cognitive
abilities began to decline making it
challenging to produce work at the same
intensity that once brought in renowned
The Strain on his mental and physical
well-being showed in the Untamed
whiteness of his hair as he Grew Older
nevertheless he did what he could he
served his Scientific Advisor to the
Trinity house a historic institution
responsible for Mariner safety around
the British Isles during Faraday's time
lighthouses served as vital guides quite
literally signaling the difference
between life and death for Sailors under
his guidance electric lighting began to
replace traditional oil in gas lamps he
was so committed to his work that even
at the age of 70. he personally went to
sea to test the reliability of the new
lights in recognition of his profound
impact on science Faraday was offered a
Knighthood which he turned down he felt
that he should remain playing Mr Faraday
to the end Faraday did however accept a
gift of a house from Queen Victoria
spending the last years of his life at
Hampton Court in London on August 25
1867 Michael Faraday died of natural
causes he was 75 years old his
gravestone in London's High Kate
cemetery is modest mirroring his
lifelong humility and standing in stark
contrast to his immense contributions to
science
despite his challenges with math
faradays shined through his deep
understanding and intuition about the
natural world like Faraday many of us
face hurdles in areas we wish to excel
in if you'd like to improve your skills
in math or any stem topic I highly
recommend brilliant a website and app
dedicated to learning math computer
science and data science interactively
and it's free free to try out I really
appreciate brilliant scientific thinking
puzzles which skips the heavy math
jargon and helps Foster an intuitive
understanding of our world much like how
Faraday approached his experiments I
personally go through Brilliance logic
courses to improve my critical thinking
skills there's something for everyone
whether you're just starting out want to
brush up on what you already know or are
ready to move on to more advanced
lessons if you're ever stuck you can
view the explanation to see where you
went wrong brilliant is free for you to
try out by going to the custom link in
my description
brilliant.org newsthink in the first 200
people the Sun up with my link will get
20 off the annual premium subscription
unlocking all of the courses thanks for
watching I'm Cindy Palm